In the last lesson,
we focused on access control, but
in particular what we called
discretionary access control.
The idea there is that access
control is about checking
if the source of a request should be
able to gain access to a resource.
We know that who the user
is because user comes and
authenticates himself or herself.
So in discretionary access control,
we said whoever creates the resource
is the owner of that resource.
So the owner can also selectively
grant access to other users.
For example, Bob may both be able
to read and write, and Charlie
can either read or write or maybe just
has read access or something like that.
So the idea of a discretionary
access control model is
that resources have
owners who are users.
And these owners get to decide,
it's at their discretion, who else
should be able to share these resources.
In this lesson, we're going to examine
if this model has any limitations or
any problems.
Are there situations where it's
not going to do the job for us?
And if that is the case, then what other
kind of models do we need to develop
to meet those applications, or
those needs that arise when
we talk about access control?